be
[Music]
be Barn finger
family hello farm animals 1 2 3 4
[Music]
5 oh no where is my farm finger
family cow finger cow finger where are
you here I am here I am how do you do
cow finger cow finger what do you say
mo that's what I say hello hello Finger
Family
[Music]
dog finger dog finger where are you here
I am here I am how do you do dog finger
dog finger what do you say quack quack
quack quack quack quack that's what I
say hello hello f finger
family quack quack quack
sheep finger sheep finger where are you
here I am here I am how do you do sheep
finger sheep finger what do you say
baa that's what I say hello hello finger
[Music]
family my chicken
chicken finger chicken finger where are
you here I am here I am how do you do
chicken finger chicken finger what do
you say quack quack quack quack quack qu
that's what I say hello hello finger
[Music]
family have you seen my Piggy
no h let's spread out and look for it
Pig finger Pig finger where are you here
I am here I am how do you do pig finger
Pig finger what do you say oink oink
oink oink oink oink that's what I say
hello
hello oink oink oink
[Music]
hit the Subscribe button